SAROS, AND THE PUCK TAKENRTANT N
THE TEAM.
THIS COACH,
CANADIEN.
FIRST ROUND PICK.
16thLINE, YOU'D
CENTERS.
IT'S BROKEN UP BY GRANLUND. SCO
THAT PLAYOFF RUN AND
THEY GO TO WORK.
FOR GEORGIEV, HE'S GOT TO BE
SHARP THTH
EKHOLM HOLDING AS THE PREDATORS
CHANGE.
FORSBERG PLAYING IT ACROSS. SKID
NUMBER ONE, SITTING MAKES ONE S
THE REBOUND COMES BACK OUT.
HE STAYS IN POSITION.
WATCH HOW HE'S IT UP.
THIS IS TRENIN.
SHOT BLOCKED BY TRENIN.
PLAYED UP THE BOARDS BY POWER-PY
GOALS.
WHO HAD MORE.
TWEETT
RANGERS HAVE FOX AND LINDGREN O
MAN RIGHTDEFLECTED.
I DON'T THINK
BROUGHT TO YOUTHAT, HERE'S .
NASHVILLE PREDATORS.BOARDS.
SCORES.
PHILIP TOMASINO
RIGHT SIDE.
ALL THE RANGERS ARE ON THE BOAR.
CHYTIL.
LAFRENIERE AFTER IT.
JOSITURNOVER HERE.
RANGERS GET THEIR FAUX CHECK
GOING AND JILLION A NASHVILLE.
SHOTS F. FACT ABOUT IT
AFTER THE HITS HE  PRIOR TO THA.
FOX.
PANARIN'S SHOT BLOCKED.D.
RIGHT-HANDED SHOT WHICH MEANS
THE PUCK TOOK A LITTLE LONGER TO
GET THERE.
IF HE HAD BEEN